stop video i have a very very exciting
announcement to make another pewdiepie
rhino shield collaboration
we have so many cool new designs i'm
super proud of these
you guys love the last one we did it's
very epic
for those who don't know rhino shield
thus these phone cases are just insanely
durable we did a drop test last time
to see if it was actually true and it
literally broke might says furnace stone
plate
you can see them testing out their cases
as well you can literally throw them
anywhere and the phone
seems completely fine not that i
recommend doing that but it just
it's a testimony to just how quality
these phone cases are
but not just quality the designs are so
freaking cool
so if you got the iphone uh you can get
this clear kind of case to it
oh sorry it's a bit dirty let me polish
it up with my
pewdiepie microfiber cloth that comes
free with any order baby
hell yeah love this design very epic
they were so requested that we have the
the regular weight pattern
last time we did a pixelated version
which i thought was cool
but a lot of you guys wanted just the
regular waves
and i i don't know if you guys care but
i love being able to customize
small details and rhino shield really
does that so you can change out these
two different colors like the border
no problem you can also change the
buttons
in different colors to really make the
phone unique and as you saw earlier
now you can also add your name or
whatever epic thing you want to put on
it
10 letters you can do it meme it up meme
search go crazy go nuts i love this
design
it looks so good dangerously close to
the what is it do a lipa
or no i don't know the album cover but
it's slick
so cool hey custom buttons
sick the wave pattern is available in 20
different colors
god damn this design is available in
different ways as well
make this case your own you know baby we
also got the zero death case
sick they ship worldwide anywhere you
are
we ship it to you no excuse not to get
it this time gamers
there's also i didn't know about this
lifetime warranty on these
phone cases that's how confident they
are in their product
they literally hand out free
replacements oh this one
the wave is texturized it's really sick
look at that baby
available for iphones androids any
flagship
kind of devices we got you covered and
don't forget
literally 20 not 10 not 15
20 off if you enter the code pewdiepie
and order
within 48 hours from this video from the
time you see this
go go go don't miss out on that offer
it's seriously amazing
if you happen to watch this at a way
later date you can still use the code
pewdiepie
but you get 10 off instead of 20. so
make sure you don't miss out this is a
great phone cases i love using them
i always have them on my phone and guess
what my phone has never broke since i
used it so
and i break my phone all the time thank
you rhinoshield super excited about this
link is in the description
try not to cringe let's do this if i
cringe in this video
something at the end of the video will
happen oh my god let's go
this is already cringe what the [ __ ] how
long the video hasn't started don't
[ __ ] tell me to subscribe
guys subscribe to this channel right now
i met me by the way
we need to make but some people are
enjoying this i think
kinda uncomfortable
[Laughter]
it's such a powerful thing to be able to
sit through cringe
i have no idea what his stand-up was to
be fair he could be a jackass but
the fact that he's just like oh
confrontation instead of just oh i'll go
he's like
of program i'm enough the tech has to
leave for an event the tech has to leave
yeah they better be leaving
they better go then why would this come
up now
is it because i'm talking about
uncomfortable stuff
i think you can be uh respectful while
being uncomfortable
like i i think there's a distinction
between me uncomfortable being
disrespectful
[Applause]
i didn't take it long for her to listen
up on the light
the tech has to go oh we didn't like the
jokes if he was a really good comedian
he could make this
awkward tension really funny and make
them look as foolish as they are
oh now look look like i said i already
got paid
so i'm good
closing remarks yeah 30 minutes of them
[Laughter]
all right we get the point he leaves
that's pretty cringe
well done ladies you handled that
and it's a professionally that i have to
end this way but the show is not ending
because we have some final remarks oh i
can't wait to see what's next on the
show
oh this is a razer seamless scene this
is a racer ceo
oh no okay let's see if we can keep the
sponsorship just
99.99 right after this keynote remember
built in
kitty ears are you kidding me available
right here today
and something that we've kind of come up
together with our friends at tiktok
is a challenge and we call it
the hashtag razer learn to meow dance
challenge
all right and we've put together a quick
video
i missed out on these why didn't they
ask me
do i got it is this cringe are you
cringing right now
that was tough guys
[Music]
i don't know why these two are fighting
i haven't followed it at all
this is what i'm talking about look
why what is that
that punch sounded like i heard jake
more than ashgren
how dare you do that to me
so if the plane have pooped in the rug
twice can the defendant throw her out
what in the world is happening on
television lately
what they can ask people's opinion i
can't wait
i mean you got a game you got a game sir
what can i say
we've all been there in super mario
smash
tetris you gotta keep going maybe the
first time i'll let it slide but not the
second time poop me one shame on me
right
bro just poop in the shower my dude but
no one told him
accident uh yeah but um two times i
don't think so
here's how to apply this to a woman
while you're talking to her oh is this a
pickup artist yes
then look at her and appreciate her
beauty
let the sexual feelings build up to the
point that you want to ravish her
that's not necessary and just keep
talking
because your facial expressions will
translate what you're thinking slow down
your voice
and have strong eye contact strong eye
contact is key
hi i just saw you here and
i had to at least say hi
hi i'm matt nice to meet you
nice to meet you all right
let me try it hey
i can't even do it as a joke
don't ever ever listen to these pickup
artist douchebags
ever ever would you let me do that
when you get it right you'll notice that
she'll reciprocate
don't do that don't do that don't learn
from movies either
[Applause]
okay this is fun hey
yeah let's go okay this is
hilarious this is so funny
there you go raise the roof clean the
hands raise the roof wash your feet
i feel you
this is very cringe uh okay i get it so
it's kind of lame but have you ever been
to an anime convention
everyone [ __ ] reeks dude clearly it's
not common fact
to keep sanitized clearly it's not
common knowledge
to wash your hands so i think
fine if this was what it takes fine fine
but you know everybody's wondering about
my legs
what happened to your leg i'm like well
everybody heard us doing this comedy
show and they're like break a like
so i did and you think gums blondes are
dumb
i didn't expect actual pain dude i'm
gonna go
in and do something very special and
barkley's tea and coffee
come with me the the this person has
that
i'm a mom and i like to embarrass my
kids vibe i've written all over her
oh that looks good man i want to get
a lavender vanilla latte
oh okay lavender vanilla
oh she said voice actors
[Music]
is that bart simpson was that bart
simpson well i have a little
cold in my throat right now
oh yeah are you okay
look straight what's your name i'm good
i'm daniel
yeah nice hi daniel i'm bart simpson
what's going on
yes it's all right it is kind of sweet
sure
sure neat stay woke be on fleek
and get that gucci breakfast goals say
bye felicia to that testing stress
weather's gonna be turned right chris
yes
the weather gonna be the lit during
testing week
a 100p chance of success you've got this
kids
steve how about that traffic are we
looking okay
better than oh we're talking turn
fomo around
any tps schools to keep you from taking
those tests
heck yeah wendy williams burp and fart
at the same time she's not lonely
double kill
adele respected 27 years old you're old
enough to understand political
correctness in the times that we live
now you can't just she's ready to let
that
rip she's like how much can i
and i'm just gonna uh i'm waiting for it
you're lucky you only got battery
i mean
wendy williams wendy willy oh they made
the joke god damn it
listen i fart all the time during my
live stream i always think
people that are alive for like hours and
hours they must let them rip and lose
all the time
there must be a compilation now think
about it do i want to google this
why am i watching this
it doesn't count as other people she's
not lonely
she's what happened to her
face she got a mustache the surprise of
burp
let out a fart and it's this is glorious
you are waiting on word from the
guinness book of world records
and that should be a mere formality
right because you hit you hit 31 in a
minute it's on video yeah i don't see
how it could be denied yeah definitely
and honestly if for some reason there
was an issue i could break it again for
sure guy breaks about breaking world
record with 31
made three pointers in one minute in one
minute and he has to just do three
welcome just shoot cuz if i make the
first one i won't put too much pressure
on
okay all right there you go all right
there it is see that's all i thought
it's the shirt it's the shirt that's
tight and he hit it
it's the shirt that's tight ernie
you know what i'm saying oh another maze
it's the first it's the shirt that's
tight but it's the form that's never
touched
and he hit it
i could easily do it
oh curve your arrogance okay this is an
infamous incident i never heard of this
off-camera voice that has to tell her to
smile honey smile what's this one
well this is going to be up linked to
most of the stations across the country
that are eager to hear about him
who is nancy kerrigan here just wanted
to welcome you back during a parade
kerrigan complained to mickey mouse
it's so corny so dumb i hate it the most
corny thing i've ever done
disney also arranged for kerrigan to
make appearances on the morning talk
shows today in la viewers got only an
empty chair
until kerrigan finally showed up only
seconds before the end of the show
hi southern california apparently
somebody forgot to remind nancy kerrigan
that disney is paying her a reported two
million dollars to make television
appearances like these
a movie and a tv deal someone forgot to
tell her
i was on her side until they tell you
about the bank it's like all right come
on
you did a deal at least follow through
right so for
context she said that she said it in the
context of
having to wear her medal in the parade
she said her parents had always taught
her not to show off
and brag about accomplishments i can
totally get this
yeah not that my parents told me that
but like yeah it's kind of lame to just
oh i want a medal i'm just gonna wear it
all around
that's interesting i'm more interested
in anything wait this is a reason
this is literally three days ago madonna
accused of photoshopping her head onto
fans body
so she posted this it's clearly
photoshopped anyone can tell that
and that's very uncomfortable
when monado posts a photo of herself to
instagram to promote her album but it's
actually your body i'm not
who photoshops their face on a random
girl's body and pretend it's theirs as
another perplexing fan adding i'm so
confused
[Music]
was she on drugs i doubt that she's the
one that photoshopped this she probably
saw a photoshop of someone else that
didn't posted it
oh this one yes uriah west yes
i don't know what this is exactly
apparently you can have like a public
speak to the council of your city and
people
take it to make it really funny pledge
of allegiance because i'm canadian so i
kind of went with it
i did vote in the last election even
though i'm canadian i'm like ah let's
see what happens
if uh if a russia can vote why can't i
canada i'm not right to the sun you know
so just sitting there
you know on the bench sweating sweating
like a republican
applying for food stamps
uh i get i get making a couple of jokes
but also like okay so why are you here i
kind of want to
know i have issues parking i don't know
i feel weird i can always park
i went down the you know las vegas man
group
if that was the only joke that's kind of
funny and then my car broke down
they say what happens to vegas stays in
vegas in this case it was my karma
dreams
because see i had triple a but you know
i'm from canada right so i'm the
canadian version
it's when three canadians get out uh and
fight over who's going to help you
triple a
more respect for city council than what
you guys
probably are feeling right now with me
talking
i am american i didn't commit voter
fraud that was a joke just uh
just to clear things up why it was a
liar what the hell did
oh it's so s it's so quiet it's so cold
in there can you feel how cold that is
oh i'm shivering up the greyhound is the
cards against humanity of travel
you just never know if you're gonna get
stabbed am i right
wasting my time thinking people don't
think anymore like a live twitter feed
at this point
you know what i mean it kind of seemed
like it i was watching
maybe this isn't going so well no i
wasn't
maybe i should just stop ironically this
is the funniest one
i was watching no it wasn't well this
makes me happy you see what i mean with
the cringe
you see what i mean it gives me life
karen objects at son's weddings
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow everybody has vlogs and that's why i
love them
you can leave judy like you don't have
flaws
you can get out of my wedding i'm not
leaving get fresh you're wearing
unpaid for get out i'm not getting out
please
try it and i'll have your wrists that's
messed up
oh girl thought she was muted during
zoom climbs
this class is stupid i don't need to
hear it oh no
love that rude
[Music]
yes please
old zuck classic i miss this station
this is mark zuckerberg at facebook can
you hear me okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
so hey mark ready loud and clear it's a
pleasure to talk with you today
i think we should start by can you it's
our pleasure can you um
introduce yourselves and your roles and
how long you've been working up there
for
i mean you can't obviously it's delayed
[Music]
right
this is edited come on it's still great
hey we got jared leto again everyone's
favorite douche bag apparently
on the count of three
one two three jump
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on yo
you with your fingers and your chin
beard what are you sitting on your
[ __ ] ass for
oh
this is the 30 seconds tomorrow show
[Applause]
what if he had like a disability or
something like what
no don't look behind you i'm looking at
you oh my god
yes you oh thank you very much
[Applause]
i would say i would keep setting that
kim i gotta watch this again
and on that note when did william burp
fart on the smash and subscribe button
thanks for watching this video don't
forget to check out the 20
offer if you enter code pewdiepie these
are amazing phone cases
it's a great gift it's a great life
protect your phone
and that's it thanks for supporting the
channel i see you guys bye bye